for more information on tutoring or how
to support moofy university and the
production of more videos please visit
moof university com thank you and enjoy
now that we've discussed the wave nature
of light let's tuck talk a little bit
about the particle nature of light as
well as the photoelectric effect and
plunks postulate so what is the
photoelectric effect well I'll define it
in a moment but let's think about this
situation here we've got little cube or
block of sodium metal and we're going to
shine some light on it in one case will
shine blue monochromatic light and
another case will shine red
monochromatic light what happens when we
shine the blue monochromatic light what
ends up happening is that electrons sort
of fly off of this metal electrons are
emitted okay but when the red
monochromatic light is shine on the
metal no electrons are emitted and even
if the brightness of the red
monochromatic light is increased there's
still no electrons emitted increasing
the brightness to create a more intense
beam did not have any effect okay why
that why is that that's something we'll
come back to but this this concept over
here what's going on with the blue
monochromatic light this is the
photoelectric effect this is the
photoelectric effect when a
monochromatic light of a high enough
frequency shines on a metal plate to
cause electrons to be emitted that is
the photoelectric effect so this model
this blue monochromatic light shines in
this metal causes electrons to be
emitted and it has a high enough
frequency okay so we'll get into that in
a second so why did the blue light cause
the electrons to be emitted and why did
the red light not the same well blue
light must have had a high enough
frequency in fact its frequency is equal
to approximately 6.5 times 10 to the
14th hurts while the red light had a
frequency of 4.5 times
10 to the 14th hurts so the blue light
had a greater frequency now this
photoelectric effect this concept could
not be explained by the wave model for
light so this dude might have heard of
him Albert Einstein he sort of came up
with the idea that light behaves as
though it's made of particles that he
called photons so photons are basically
little packets or particles of light and
he said that these particles these
particles of light these photons had
energy that is related to their
frequency ok and of course if something
is related to its frequency then it must
be related to its wavelength as well ok
so let's move on enter max plunk some
people say plank I are no maybe it's
blank plank plunk get a postulate and
his postulate was that it was a
basically this equation that the energy
of a photon was equal to H nu nu of
course being the frequency and H is is
equal to six point six two six times ten
to the negative 34 jules times seconds
this is a constant value that was plunks
constant or Planck's constant ok now you
can imagine here that if a unit is equal
to jules times seconds and we're
multiplying by 1 over seconds that the
seconds will cancel and you'll be left
with jewels and jewels are the SI unit
for energy ok so we get the energy of a
photon is equal to this so also this as
a side note 1 jul is equal to 1 kilogram
times meter squared per second squared
that is an important fact that will come
up later in chemistry and it also comes
up at physics and in truth a lot of the
times physics and chemistry overlap ok
so now i do want to mention something
else so this is the equation or plunks
postulator equation but recall though
that c equals lambda nu
I so lambda a new are related so if i
solve this for new i divide both sides
by 8 by the wavelength i get nu equals C
over lambda and I can plug this in for
new because it equals new so I can then
write the equation as the energy of a
photon equals H times C over lambda okay
so this equation is basically the same
this basically means that if you know
the frequency of a certain light then
you could find the energy with photon
all right or if you know the wavelength
you do the same thing right these
equations are the same same thing right
if you just consider the fact that we're
using this other equation to sort of
manipulate a little bit okay so what's
the important fact here or the port an
idea is that the energy of a photon is
proportional directly proportional to
the frequency that means a higher
frequency higher energy right and it's
the energy of the photon is also
proportional inversely proportional to
the wavelength because here we have if
we if this wavelength is larger they let
energy the photon is smaller okay so
let's use this equation to find the
energy the blue photon and the energy
the red photon so from the blue light
the the frequency was 6.5 times 10 to
the 14th hurts so we're going to take e
equals H nu so H is Planck's constant so
we'll have six point six to six times
ten to the negative 34 Jules times
seconds times so that's H and then new
is for the blue photon 6.5 times 10 to
the 14th hurts or one over seconds so
here the seconds will cancel and we're
left with jewels and that value if we
plug that into your calculator you'll
get four point three times 10 to the
negative 19 joules
the same thing for the red photon 6.6 to
6 times 10 to the night of 34 jewels
times seconds times its frequency which
was what was it 4.5 yeah 4.5 times 10 to
the 14th one over seconds again the
seconds will cancel and we'll be left
with jewels and in this case the answer
is 3.0 times 10 to the negative 19
joules negative 19 joules so this is the
energy of the red photon and this is the
energy of each blue photon and sometimes
these will be these could be written
that sometimes I'll be dritten as jewels
sometimes they'll actually just be
written as joules per photon and joules
per photon so we'll add that on there to
the end so so what's the idea here the
point is that the energy the blue photon
of each blue photon is higher than the
energy of each red photon ok so the
photons in the blue light were higher in
energy than the photons in the red light
ok so let's scroll back up here just
what we said we come back to so I
mentioned that increasing the brightness
of the red light to create a more
intense beam to not have any effect why
is that well that's because when you
increase the brightness or the intensity
of a light beam what you're doing is
you're increasing the number of photons
not you're not increasing their energy
so doesn't matter how many you know
these red photons you shine at this the
sodium metal their energy the energy of
each one is not high enough to knock
electrons loose okay so whereas the the
blue monochromatic lights photons were
higher in energy and they were capable
of causing the electrons to be emitted
so what's a good analogy here analogy
would be like if you have a glass table
and you dropped one
ball of lead on it versus dropping 100
ping-pong balls on the glass table
what's what's going on there well one
ball of light if you drop it on on on a
glass table it'll probably shatter the
glass right even though it's just one
one ball but if you have a hundred
ping-pong balls it doesn't matter that
you have a hundred right because the
ping-pong balls themselves are not going
to break the glass table right it's kind
of the idea here whereas it's kind of
like the blue monochromatic light is is
like one ball of lead versus the really
bright but not powerful enough red and
monochromatic light photons shining on
the the sodium metal kinda like the
ping-pong balls so I hope that makes
sense there so furthermore the energy of
a photon is is said to be quantized
which means that it's it's got a fixed
energy it's a fixed quantity right if
you have a certain frequency that is
going to be associated with a certain
energy right and that energy is fixed
it's not a continuous it's not
continuous so this is an important
concept for the for the idea of atomic
line spectra which is coming up in the
next series so I hope that video was
helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
Like comment subscribe and share with
friends thank you and happy studying